the only thing that I can see that is
distinctly different about me is I'm not
afraid to die on a treadmill I will run
I will not be be out work period you
might have more talent than me you might
be smarter than me you might be sexier
than me you might be all of those things
you got it on me in nine categories but
if we get on the treadmill together
there's two things you're getting off
first yeah or I'm gonna die it's really
that simple
so let's go back to the question about
what if people block me out it's do is
going to be two options I'm gonna get
back in or I'm gonna be dead you're not
going to outwork me it's such a simple
basic concept the guy who is willing to
hustle the most is gonna be the guy that
just gets that loose ball I was going to
be out of bounds but he saved it back in
it's like the commodity that I see the
majority of people who aren't getting to
places they want or aren't achieving the
things that they want this business is
strictly based on hustle it's strictly
based on being outworked it's strictly
based on missing crucial opportunities I
say all the time if you stay ready you
ain't gotta get ready the separation of
talent and skill is one of greatest
misunderstood concepts for people who
are trying to excel who have dreams
talent you have naturally skill is only
developed by hours and hours and hours
of beating on your craft there's no easy
way around it no matter how talented you
are your talent is going to fail you if
you're not skilled if you don't study if
you don't work really hard and dedicate
yourself to being better every single
day
you just watch - amazing clips from Will
Smith take the next three minutes to sit
quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]